this is one of my favorite examples of
doublespeak and just messing with people
in the dumbest ways Chris Cuomo from CNN
interviewed a Trump Lackey one of these
generic totally homogeneously reflexive
Trumpets about Russian interference in
the 2016 election and the guy that was
interviewed is Michael Caputo and I
actually Josh Kant former FBI agent Josh
Campbell we follow each other on Twitter
he tweeted a clip of this and I asked
who is this guy because in the clip I
first saw he wasn't labeled and Michael
Caputo himself wrote back and said it's
me try Google which I did and now we're
doing a story about it and there's this
really interesting underlying issue here
which is that because of modern
technology a country can attack another
country through technology that doesn't
require the launching of a bomb it
doesn't require someone on a plane you
certainly don't have to leave the
comfort of your office in your home
country and Chris Cuomo on CNN referred
to Russian interference as an act of war
and we can debate whether it is or isn't
an act of sort of declaratory war but
the former Trump advisor Michael Caputo
played word games truly reminiscent of
George Orwell's 1984 when he said
Russian cyberattacks weren't acts of war
they were military attacks on our
country which is sort of what an act of
war is let's take a look at the video
clip it is fascinating word games this
story of collusion and you know meddling
in our election is is completely
political and we exported that with
reporters it's factual it's not it's no
it was an act of war it was a cyber
attack on our campaign that you just
said happened so how is it a political
war Trump is the one making a political
buy the conflation by your own
definition the president is politicizing
which should be simply factual well I
would I don't know that it's an act of
war but it certainly was a military
attack on our on our country well when
the military
attacks another country how I understand
that Chris but it when but I don't want
war and that's why I want my president
to engage with Vladimir Putin
that's what war is and of course as soon
as Caputo realizes that when he's
describing an act of war by when he says
it's not war he changes his argument to
well I don't want war which is fine but
that's a completely different story and
discussion altogether it isn't a movie
it's a story told by a camera through a
set of moving images in a theater or on
a television set with actors playing
roles it isn't a dog it's a domesticated
carnivorous mammal of the canine family
often kept as a pet or for work in
fields this is insanity do words have
meaning anymore and they're there when
we talk about post-modernism you have
people disproportionately on the right
but also on the left who sometimes
fairly will criticize post-modernism as
a movement which in some ways has sort
of removed all objective meaning from
language and from the world and then
they say it's not war it's a military
attack on our country and Caputo also
during this interview tried to blame the
media for how this entire fiasco around
Russia has developed which of course is
also the opposite of the truth right
were it not for the media what Trump did
and has done would more likely be
skirting by unnoticed and this is once
again reminiscent of 1984 take a look at
the second clip I don't think the
president is the only one in this
political system in United States
that's guilty of conflating the two
issues of meddling and collusion I think
the media does that constantly I think
the resistance doesn't constantly and I
think they do it because they they've
kind of cracked the code they know that
it really sets the president off and the
media didn't go to Helsinki to find out
what's gonna happen with Ukraine and
Crimea or Syria or Kaliningrad or or
even nuclear proliferation or nuclear
modernization they went there with a
gotcha question yeah
Trump didn't exactly go to Helsinki and
make progress
those issues either and I've talked a
lot this week about how a lot of what's
going on right now is more like brave
new world by Aldous Huxley than it is
like 1984 in the sense that you hear
every position on an issue and you no
longer can even discern what the truth
is this is more like Orwell's 1984 where
they're just completely arbitrary and
new definitions being concocted for even
the simplest of terms that we sort of
use in everyday life words no longer
have meaning other than the meanings
that truncus want them to have and this
is you know we're we're beyond pointing
out hypocrisy we're beyond pointing out
that there seems to be no concern for
the morality of ethics of sort of
whether we adhere to the founding
principles of the United States
we're completely beyond that it's now
becoming very very rudimentary and the
questions to be answered are gonna be
answered in really simple ways are we on
board and do we have a consensus that
what is taking place in our country is
unacceptable at such a fundamental level
that number one Republicans must be
removed from having control of the House
and Senate November 6 2018 for the
Congress that will be sworn in January
of 2019 are we going to have any
consequences for the top people that
have been involved in the carrying out
of arguably traitorous and bordering on
treasonous behavior before during and
after the 2016 election and most
importantly is the hyper normalization
that we're experiencing right now and I
I'm a victim of it right I am totally
desensitized by the almost daily
scandals any one of which could have
conceivably taken down a presidency 20
years ago are we going to be so affected
by that hyper normalization that in the
future there will be even more Trump
like candidates and administration's
that are allowed to get away completely
scot-free I mean yeah okay Michael Flynn
was indicted and so is manna Ford in 25
Russians and
ha da polis but big picture we've not
yet seen serious sentences we don't know
where it's going to shake up is this the
new normal of American politics and I've
talked before about how
disproportionately the governor's
convicted of corruption our New Jersey
governor's is the United States going to
become the world New Jersey when it
comes to this degree of normalized
corruption and criminality or are we
going to do something about it we may
not have the answer until November 6th
2018 and and we may not even get it then
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and boy do we have a good
one today some shows and I could take
them or leave them but this is actually
going to be a pretty good show today's
program is sponsored in part by fruit or
the tour is a social forecasting game
where players come together and compete
with each other to predict future events
you open up the game on your phone or
web browser you'll see a whole range of
forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real-world
events using food tours in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on foot or you can find my account
by clicking the link in the description
if you're watching this on YouTube and
you can sign up now at futurecom and
start making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm